depressions up anxieties up from a lack
of innocence right hi I'm Mateo I am
sixteen and I build robots I'm Taylor
I'm 18 and I'm really passionate about
singing in about music hi I'm Isabella
I'm 16 and I fly a plane which is a
Cessna 172
hi I'm fanny and I not gonna say my age
filmmaker I'm Elizabeth I'm 39 plus 1
and I am a film director I'm Jeremiah
I'm 41 I'm a Regional Sales Manager for
a telecom company well I'm sorry
so right now I'm learning every like a
new thing every day but like if I had a
lot more years than by the time I'm like
90 I'll know everything yeah yeah just
simple things like with learning how
people around you act that you learned
so much that you're not gonna learn as a
10 year old
I think it's Paris I'd like to say I
feel I know nothing I mean literally
every day I say to you I'm just guessing
and the older I've got the more I've
realized that everybody else around me
is winging it and they don't know
everything either and we're all just
trying our best like when you're young
you're like I know everything about
everything you know no from what I know
to what I don't know that's you know
those two things are just completely on
opposite ends of the spectrum for me
all teens are rocking beautiful yes but
it's forced on you and a lot earlier age
online for teen boys I mean they can
find horrible images everywhere I
definitely do agree that there's a lot
more exposure it's not like an
intentional thing I don't think kids are
just like worse it's just easier to get
caught up in bad situations okay well I
personally think that we're more
innocent now because parents you guys
could get away with a lot more back in
the day yeah it was we were naughty we
did a lot of things my parents never
knew but now I can I can you know check
on his phone where he's at and but
sometimes you go down the rabbit hole
where you do think your kids are super
innocent and then you realize oh they
have to snap what's this other snap
what's it what's this other Instagram oh
I have a dead one you don't know about
everybody has you know I think you have
to be more devious well I mean this one
time I got Instagram and all my friends
out of me they added me to the first
Instagram account though cheap parents
don't see and I was slightly
disappointed in them as people but I
didn't know you had Instagram feet I got
rid of it I think you have to give
credit to some other kids I do I think
that there are some kids who haven't got
to Instagram and actually Trust is the
biggest element for me as a parent I
trust her yeah I mean if the question
was do you think your teen is innocent
oh and I say teens uh 50/50 your friends
but RIT suicide rates are up depressions
up anxieties up comes from a lack of
innocence right I know three or four
people in my class that had those
problems but they weren't spoken of I
definitely agree that it's more I do
I think for me it's I don't know if you
know how much I almost judge myself by
seeing other people on social media yeah
I do because let me tell you I worry
every day you don't know this when I'm
on your social media looking at all
these other things that people have been
doing just hoping you haven't seen it or
that you're not affected by it so I
worry about that all the time but I
don't say anything about it
cuz this problem won't be a surprise
because he saw my grades from that year
but in sophomore year I skipped math
class like all the time it was awful
so yeah is that you know one of the
things that I don't think you know about
me is like I feel like I'm always
holding my breath you know I'm a lot
softer person I'm you know when I get
bored on my work conference call they
tell you I doodle but I actually I write
poetry and it a lot but I don't exactly
like to talk about it or put it out
there I wish I knew more how was your
day good
please tell me what's going on please I
just want to know like I could tell you
a lot more about what I do but it's free
more like today on the way here you told
me you're working on a documentary when
you know I'm a documentarian like sure
and I know these names like this way I
do for a living you know I only have a
couple years left before you go to
college I really want to be a part of it
yeah I mean I made the decision to have
kids and I gave up that control of
really for me what I had to raise a
family and and it's like my own fault
but I got kids out of it that's great
I'll take the win on that but you know I
want more control in in terms of what I
want to do that's gonna make me happy
and more fulfilled why I feel like I
want more control it's not
I wouldn't mean I wouldn't say it's your
mom it's I just would like like to be
doing more things by now there's so many
things that I wish I knew like for music
and like making an actual song and
things like that so I feel like it's
more of that environment holding me back
then like home life for me I really
didn't feel like I was a good roll my
own life now that I'm 40 I feel like I'm
finally grown into Who I am truly as an
adult and owning it I'm in charge of my
own life there's nobody else
I'm personally good with I'm out of
control I have though I'd like it if you
can show me how to control it myself
when I finally go to college and I'm an
impending I can actually have to do
these things yeah I think I'm currently
very happy where I am with what I
control clean understand that there are
some things that I don't have control
over and I think when the divorce
happened having your parents break up
there's to see something as big as that
that is something I hadn't no control
over but I knew that I could control how
my room looked what I ate what I wore I
kind of embraced and took hold of
because I knew that that's all I had
control over
why are you shaking your head
like there's always room for improvement
that I like even if you're at like the
best you always want to get a better
relationship with your parents got it I
just I feel like it's so I had kids when
I was 20 by the time I was 22 I had both
my kids because I was young parent I
look at my kids I go oh that really that
mess that messed him up
dang it they're gonna remember that one
you know I just it's like it's hard
because I know I haven't been you know
completely perfect one I wish I could
have a bunch of redos but I can't so
moving forward I want to try to continue
to work on and get closer for sure like
at this point what like both like me and
you are looking for is just how to how
to have like the father/daughter
connections still after high school and
I think we both feel that really hard
right now yeah I also had them young and
you know I'm divorced so single mom with
two kids and this is pursuing the career
while dating and I always feel like oh
my gosh I did the whole thing wrong
because there I am going on dates and so
I do feel like it had an impact in them
especially Matt Dale was my youngest you
were a lot like you always got a lot but
doesn't really change their relationship
that much I don't think you having to
date was a bad thing or having me really
you know you probably could've way to go
before and there's an apple there's
always still room for improvement it's
not me saying that I wish the
relationship would stay where it was I
think we're in a good place I just don't
feel right now that it needs to be
better well in that I don't think it's
definitely not perfect
yeah but we're learning at the same time
can improve it constantly oh yeah
constantly checking in every day with
each other we're always changing and I
think you have to work with that hey
guys Kendra from jubilee here thank you
so much for watching this series middle
ground we are so passionate about
inspiring radical empathy so let us know
what you think in the comments below
make sure to subscribe follow us on
Instagram and we'll see you next time